Trying to comprehend
how big the Universe is
is one of those questions
that astrophysicists
grapple with all the time.
Trying to explain it in a way
that's easy to understand,
well that's a whole other challenge.
In 1977, Charles and Ray Eames,
hugely influential
American designers,
released one of the most elegant
and creative pieces
of science communication
of modern times -
Powers of Ten.
It took the viewers on a journey from
a picnic blanket near Lake Michigan
to the edge of the known Universe,
and back again.
Over 40 years later,
as a humble homage
to this groundbreaking film,
we're going to take a similar journey
through time and space
and see how our understanding
has changed along the way.
As in 1977,
we'll start with a picnic.
Though this time, we're
on the island of Sicily in Italy,
rather than Lake Michigan.
We'll start with a scene
one metre wide,
viewed from one metre away,
and every 10 seconds, we're going
to move out to 10 times further away,
so the scene will be 10 times wider.
This square is 10 metres wide,
and in 10 seconds, the next square
will be 10 times that.
The movement may seem linear,
but we're actually accelerating
exponentially into the distance.
This square is 100 metres wide,
the distance someone
can run in 10 seconds.
Well, if they're running at 43km/h,
just under the speed of your cat.
One kilometre, though our picnickers
are indistinguishable now,
we can still clearly see the impact
of human activity on the world.
Ten thousand metres,
or 10 to the 4 metres,
this is the distance a supersonic
plane travels in 10 seconds,
and we're now reaching the highest
altitude flown by such a plane.
10 to the 5 metres,
this is the distance the
International Space Station travels
in 10 seconds.
There it goes.
From here on, human activity
will be lost to sight,
we're at the scale of countries.
One million metres,
or 10 to the 6 metres,
we've long left Earth's atmosphere,
and soon we'll see the whole planet.
What a jewel.
Ten million metres.
The invisible magnetosphere
shields us from the dangerous
ionising radiation of space.
10 to the 8 metres.
This line extends
at the speed of light.
This is the time it takes for light
to reach us from the moon's orbit,
the age of moonlight.
The Earth is now just a pale blue dot
in a sky full of stars.
Even as we accelerate away,
the stars appear stationary because
they're so much further away.
So much empty space.
Let's illustrate the orbits of the
planets in our solar system,
otherwise this could get a bit dull.
Here comes the orbit of Venus,
then Mars,
and now Mercury.
Since 2010, the NASA
Solar Dynamics Observatory
has been using an extreme
ultraviolet filter
to monitor the activity of our Sun.
Finally, we reach the orbit
of the outer planets,
the gas giants, but just
specks at this distance.
There's the orbit of Pluto, one of
the dwarf planets of the Kuiper belt.
10 to the 13 metres, and we're
moving out of the solar system.
In 2012, the Voyager 1 spacecraft
became the first human artefact
to make this journey,
followed in 2018 by its twin,
Voyager 2.
Both were launched in 1977,
the year the Eames were
working on Powers of Ten.
We're heading into
interstellar space,
our Sun is just one
of billions of stars,
and still at this distance, the
night sky looks very similar
to what we see at home.
This square is 10 to the 16 metres,
the distance light travels
in one year, one light year.
Here's our closest neighbour,
Alpha Centauri.
Three stars for the price of one,
with planets orbiting around them.
I'd love to know
what's going on there.
Thanks to data collected
by the Gaia spacecraft,
we're building a detailed
3D map of the Milky Way.
There are between 100 and 400
billion stars in our galaxy alone,
and clouds of dust and gas,
like these nebulae,
where new stars are born.
Images sent from the
Hubble Space telescope
have been blowing our minds
for a generation.
As we move away, we begin to the see
the great flat spiral of our galaxy.
A few hundred billion stars rotating
around a black hole,
Sagittarius A*, 4.2 million times
more massive than our Sun.
we now think supermassive black holes
reside at the centre
of nearly all galaxies.
These two dwarf galaxies
are the Magellanic clouds
which, together
with at least 80 others,
make up what's known as
the local group of galaxies.
10 to the 22.
One million light years.
Soon we'll pass the supergiant
elliptical galaxy M87.
And if we switch to radio waves,
we can glimpse the supermassive
black hole at its centre.
Switching back to visible light, as
we traverse the Virgo Supercluster,
each tiny dot not a star,
but a galaxy.
Billions of stars floating
in an ever-growing void.
10 to the 24 metres.
The limits of our vision in 1977.
But over 40 years later,
we can show a bit more.
Clusters of galaxies arranged
along filaments,
like the Pisces-Cetus
Supercluster Complex.
At 10 to the 26 metres, we switch
our view to microwave.
We can now see the current
limit of our vision.
This light forms a wall
all around us.
The light and dark patches show
differences in temperature
by fractions of a degree,
revealing where matter was beginning
to clump together
to form the first galaxies
shortly after the Big Bang.
This light is known as the cosmic
microwave background radiation.
10 to the 27 metres.
One followed by 27 zeros.
Beyond this point, the nature of the
Universe is truly uncharted -
and debated.
This light was emitted around
380,000 years after the Big Bang.
Before this time,
the Universe was so hot
that it was not transparent to light.
Is there simply more universe
out there, yet to be revealed?
Or is this region still expanding -
generating more universe,
or even other universes
with different physical
properties to our own?
How will our understanding of the
Universe have changed by 2077?
How many more powers of ten
are out there?
From a picnic blanket on Sicily to
the very edge of our understanding,
I salute the Eames for the way
they told this beautiful story.
The story of the Universe.